what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and today we have a pretty big
league for
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness now this leak
does confirm a heavy rumor that was
going around about the twins being in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
but i mean this really isn't that much
of a spoiler we know that
wanda is going to be one of the main
characters of doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
and for the post-credits scene of one
division spoiler alert we saw her with
the darkhold and she heard her kids
so we know that that's where we were
going to leave off
with wanda her hearing her kids and then
going to try and find them
and since the next time that it's
confirmed that we're going to see her is
in multiverse of madness we can assume
that she'll be looking for her kids in
the movie
and with the help of doctor strange it
looks like she finds them
so what you're about to watch here is a
leaked audition video for the part of
tommy as in wanda's twins billy and
tommy
as a teenager talking to his brother
billy this is an audition from actor
julian debaker and because of kovid this
was taken at his home and it seems like
it's his mother or sister or friend
reading the other part to him but do pay
attention because
it does look like this is a scene that
we'll see in multiverse of madness and
if you love marvel and you want to stay
up to date on everything be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
so full credit for this leaked video
goes to the instagram account mutante
underscore e underscore orgul wholeso
and i'm just going to play the video
straight from their instagram as they
posted it it is the full thing
apparently
hey what are you doing here
it's nice to see you too
what do you want i'm here to check on
you
that's all yeah okay of course
of course you are so how you doing
well as you can see i'm not going out
that much
but at least i got some friends
um i'm reading a lot
and people are actually really nice here
i mean it's because we're all the same
i'm good for you tummy yeah
what about you i mean i i saw you on the
news
the other day oh you like my new outfit
oh well it's not
horrible yeah you hate it
no of course i don't hate it it's very
you look great
listen it's really nice to see you but
oh my god okay here we go what
i knew it i knew it i knew you were
gonna ask me something
tommy let me finish please i need to
talk to you
yeah okay i'm out of here
please just listen to me i beg you it's
about mom
what what are you telling me what's
going on
okay i'm sorry i lied it's not about mom
but just listen to me it's important
okay all right
you you got one minute one minute it's
not enough
it's a long story i just need your help
i need you
well you need me you must be pretty
disgrace
i am i'm gonna get you out of here once
you're out i explain
every i'm not living
what what do you mean you're not leaving
not
living here you don't understand
no you don't understand
i'm in the right place i'm i'm finally
happy i finally got friends
food a bed protection everything i need
people actually understand me here
out there they all think i'm crazy and
i'm some
kind of freak no they don't of course
they do you're actually one of
you're actually one of the first person
to call me that
but i get it okay i got what i deserve i
was a criminal
come on you're another criminal then
what am i doing here
i guess stealing is uh still a crime
all right
but what if what if i got released
what am i gonna do what am i supposed to
do i have nothing left out there
nothing and
i i don't want to be a thief anymore i'm
really really
really tired of running i'm exhausted
you won't have to i promise it's my
nature
okay the minute i'm out i know
i i'll start stealing some stuff again i
know it
do you know why because i know who i
am okay and i'm nothing like you
billy at least you can try but i don't
want to
i'm not going to wear a goddamn costume
just to help you a little friends and
and just the same friends have put me in
here
and all that for what just to say
people's
asses
it's it's it's not worth it so
you really don't want it to help me
of course i do but
what's the point what's the point
i mean i i think
you're asking for help to the wrong
person
and i'm sorry i really am
so as we just saw it looks like the
twins are indeed going to be in
multiverse of madness and they are going
to be teenagers and there
are a few key things to take away here
one
tommy is in prison for stealing and this
is surprising on two different levels
one he has superhuman speed so it's
weird to think that
he actually got caught stealing and was
put in prison
and two it's weird that he would even
steal in the first place and kind of be
a criminal as he calls himself however
if you noticed what he said in the video
he talked about he finally has food
a bed a place to stay so it seems like
without a mother and father
wherever they are food and everything
else could have been pretty scarce for
them
and obviously in multiverse of madness
we're going to find out where they
actually went
at the end of one division we kind of
just thought that maybe they just
ceased to exist but maybe it's like loki
maybe
people aren't actually erased they're
just sent to a different dimension or
maybe they're simply from another
universe
however when billy tells tommy it's
about mom he gets very concerned and
very shocked and he says
what do you mean so it could be that
they really haven't seen their mom since
the events of one division and they've
grown up to teenagers that means they
could have been without their mom for a
pretty long time
but i think one of the biggest things to
take away here is that
tommy says that billy and his friends
who dress up in costumes
are the ones who put him in prison what
he could be talking about here
is the young avengers whether that's in
our main universe
our sacred timeline whatever or a
different universe
it looks like the young avengers do
exist and billy
is a part of the new avengers as wiccan
which is his comic book superhero name
tommy or speed however is not a part of
the young avengers in fact it looks like
he went up against the young avengers
and lost and i'm actually thinking that
they are in a different universe because
i feel like if he was in prison and he
was causing trouble before he got in
prison
his mom would have stepped in she loved
her kids it was the hardest thing in the
world for her to let them go at the end
of one division and she is searching for
them
i doubt if she found them she'd really
let them get too far away from her
and if they were getting in trouble i
definitely feel like she would have
stepped in
so perhaps they're in a different
universe but wanda with the help of
doctor strange in multiverse of madness
find them and they bring them to the
main mcu timeline perhaps with some of
the other young avengers or perhaps
billy and tommy take it upon themselves
to form a new young avengers team in the
main
mcu timeline either way this video does
confirm that billy
and tommy will be in multiverse of
madness as
teenagers and this video pretty much
confirms a young avengers team
whether in our universe or another
exists in the mcm the marvel cinematic
multiverse so be sure to let me know
your thoughts on this
in the comments down below don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell
don't forget to give the video a like
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof